now i haven't done a video on microwaves
i want to give you my opinion
and anything that i say that conflicts
with what you know if you've
found some studies or references that
conflict put it down in the comments
section below
i'm always interested in new research
and especially research that's been
suppressed
because when you evaluate anything on
the internet a lot of times you'll find
that information is suppressed
a lot of the facts are not easily
found i mean let's take for example
crisco it's been considered
somewhat healthy for 97 years until they
found out
it's actually pretty dangerous right
so there's a lot of things in the market
for a long period of time
considered safe so i'm just going to
give you my opinion on microwaves
i do have a microwave oven i don't
really use it
it's not that i'm concerned about it i
just don't use it because i use the oven
mostly
so let's just kind of go through some
definitions here
the definition of radiating means
traveling outward
in all directions from a source okay
then we have radiation which is the
transmission of energy
in the form of particles or waves
through space or a medium
like food a body or even a wall
and so some people have this
consideration if they microwave the food
that it's going to be now radioactive in
some
way let's close it up right now there's
actually two types of radiation
you have ionizing radiation and you have
non-ionizing radiation ionizing
radiation
breaks one or more electrons
from the atom it's deeper
it can create dna damage and that would
be like
gamma rays or x-rays or even
to some degree uv radiation
but then you have non-ionizing radiation
which can disrupt bonds of molecules
but not necessarily the atoms but
in the research of microwaves apparently
it doesn't even break the bonds
it just vibrates the bonds so it might
disrupt the bonds in some way
and it creates heat so that's really how
microwaves affect the food
they're vibrating the food to a certain
degree
which creates heat all right so
microwaves
can lower the nutrient value in food
for sure depending on how long it's
being microwaved
but of course heat in general lowers the
nutrient content
in food the big problem with microwaves
is what you cook your food
in if you're using plastics the heat is
going to break down that plastic
and put it in your food and there's been
some pretty hardcore research on this
and
our bodies are accumulating a lot of
micro plastics
and this is definitely one source so
if you're going to use a microwave cook
in glass
or ceramics okay but don't use
plastics in a microwave now the other
very important point about microwaves is
that you do not
want to stand anywhere near
the microwave oven when it's on now
usually they have a little filter in
there with those little dots
do not be looking in the microwave when
you're cooking anything in fact
i would walk away to the point where
you're not even 15 to 20 feet
in the direction where that microwave is
and the reason is
this because those waves coming from the
microwave
can affect the cornea of your eye
and the last thing you want to do is
vibrate
the small molecular structures of your
eye
and start to cook the lens of the eye
which is very sensitive to heat
so you just want to be completely away
from the microwave
and a few days ago i used my emf tester
on the microwave i wanted to see how far
these waves extended from the microwave
when it was on
i had my emf set to radiation waves and
it was definitely
significant at 15 feet away from that
microwave so if you're going to use a
microwave
stand all the way to the side be away
from the microwave
hey before you go real quick i have a
course
entitled how to bulletproof your immune
system
it's a free course i want you to take it
and here's why
here's you here is your
environment everyone is
focused on this over here avoiding
your environment but what about here
what about strengthening
your immune system that's what's missing
this course will show you
how to bulletproof yourself and so you
can tolerate and resist
your environment much better by
strengthening
your own immune system i put a link down
in the description right down below
check it out and get signed up today
you